early this morning the president's
travel ban began preventing entry for
those traveling from 26 European
countries that does not include
Americans returning home Europe is now
the epicenter of the corona virus
pandemic with cases across the continent
the entire country of Italy remains
under quarantine and Norway today urged
its citizens against all foreign travel
and those overseas to return home Ian
Lee joins us now from London with the
latest good morning the number of new
coronavirus infections and deaths across
Europe keep arising the latest numbers
come as a World Health Organization has
a warning for the continent in the age
of pandemic music is medicine for the
heart and soul foreign team Italians
lifting spirits as the country reached
another grim milestone its highest daily
death toll across the continent
historical sites are empty France closed
the Louvre and Eiffel Tower Europe has
now become the epicenter of the pandemic
with more reported cases and deaths than
the rest of the world combined
apart from China countries including
Denmark Austria and Poland are closing
their borders to foreigners Spain the
most affected country after Italy issued
a state of alert outside Europe Iran
announced 85 deaths but health officials
fear the true figure may be much higher
other countries declared restrictions on
travel in Saudi Arabia authorities
banned all international flights while
New Zealand declared that all arrivals
need to self isolate for two weeks
joining countries like Israel this
decision will mean New Zealand will have
the widest ranging and toughest border
restrictions of any country in the world
here in the UK the Queen is limiting
official engagements but it's business
as usual for her government the Prime
Minister's approach is radical build
herd immunity essentially everyone gets
the virus so it won't come
that despite this warning from the w-h-o
you must take a comprehensive approach
not testing alone not contact tracing
alone not quarantine alone not social
distancing alone do it all
what makes Europe so vulnerable to the
virus is a couple of things first is the
free movement and porous borders second
once the virus took hold there has been
a lack of coordination between the
countries Jeff right Ian thank you very
much